Hi, it's Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and today I sat down with Dr. James Lynch and talked to him about the surgical intervention for trauma. You heard me right, surgery, not therapy, where the subcortical brain is regulated through injecting an aesthetic into the ganglia he's the doctor not me so i'll let him take that away but this is if you want to look it up a process called the stellate ganglion block that we're talking about, which can help patients of PTSD and trauma disorders learn to regulate emotion and control the symptoms of that disorder. I'm here with Dr. Lynch, and he's going to tell us about the stellate ganglion process,
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel。今天我采访了James Lynch医生，和他探讨了创伤的介入式治疗。你没听错，是手术，不是心理治疗。通过向神经节注射麻醉剂来调节大脑皮层下区域。他是医生，我是外行，所以具体细节由他来解释。我们要讨论的是一种叫做“星状神经节阻滞”的方法，如果你感兴趣可以去查一下。它能帮助创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和创伤障碍患者学会调节情绪，控制症状。我和Lynch医生在一起，他将为我们介绍星状神经节阻滞的过程。
which is like a surgical intervention for trauma and some other things, too. But we're kind of interested in its application for trauma here. And it probably would be funniest if I just explain how I think that it works as a non neurosurgeon. And then you can tell me you can correct where I'm wrong. But you're welcome to do that sure go ahead joel thanks for having me so yeah so the ganglia like you know the base of the brain you start to have the brain turning into the brain stem and connecting to the body and a lot of that is where trauma responses are stored so if you drill in between like the c6 and c7 vertebrae and inject anesthesia into those
这就像是针对创伤及其他一些问题的介入式手术。我们主要关注它在创伤治疗中的应用。作为一名非神经外科医生，我先解释一下我理解的原理，如果说错了，请你指正。没问题，Joel，请讲。谢谢你接受采访。好的，神经节位于大脑底部，是大脑向脑干过渡并连接身体的地方，很多创伤反应就储存在这里。所以，如果你在第六和第七颈椎之间钻孔，并向这些部位注射麻醉剂……
roots of how the body has learned to physically hold emotion and trauma, then it relaxes them and makes them be reprogrammed. Is that, is that right? Yeah, I love that you gave me that to, to start off with. So this may be helpful and then stop me if I ramble, because I think in my experience, I've been doing stelaganglian block now for over 10 years. As an adjunct to trauma-focused therapy, it's been very helpful in patients with severe anxiety as well. Pardon me. But it's one of my favorite things to talk about because when you hear about what it is that we're doing and why, it just makes total sense.
针对身体储存情绪和创伤的根源进行处理，能让它们放松并重新编程。是这样吗？是的，很高兴你以此作为开场。如果我讲得太啰嗦，请随时打断我。根据我过去10多年进行星状神经节阻滞的经验，作为创伤聚焦疗法的辅助手段，它对严重焦虑症患者也非常有效。抱歉。我非常喜欢谈论这个话题，因为当你了解我们所做的事情及其原因时，一切都显得合情合理。
And the fact that we hadn't figured this out much longer ago is a little bit puzzling. So the first thing is the stellate ganglion block. It's a very, very simple procedure. It's an ultrasound guided procedure that's done without a whole lot of fanfare. Frankly, it's been around for 100 years. So when people hear that they're usually fascinated that hang on a second this is not something new no not at all it's been around since the 1920s what's new is the application of using this procedure that's been around for quite
我们竟然没能更早发现这一点，这确实有点令人费解。首先，星状神经节阻滞是一个非常简单的过程。它是在超声引导下进行的，不需要大张旗鼓。坦白说，这项技术已经存在100年了。所以当人们听到这个时，通常会很惊讶：“等等，这不是什么新技术吗？”不，完全不是，它从20世纪20年代就存在了。新鲜的是将这种存在已久的程序应用到……
some time as a as a procedure used in pain medicine primarily the new part when i say new i mean really in the past 10 to 12 years it's been applied to treating essentially an overstimulated sympathetic nervous system. And that's exactly what it is. So the stellate ganglion block really refers to a nerve block using simple local anesthetic. And I'm only laughing because you did use the word drill. So I just want to reassure everyone. Honestly, there's no drilling involved. And the procedure takes literally a few minutes with a needle about the size of like a COVID shot or a flu shot.
长期以来，它主要作为疼痛医学的一种手段。我所说的“新”，是指在过去10到12年里，它被应用于治疗过度兴奋的交感神经系统。事实确实如此。星状神经节阻滞是指使用简单的局部麻醉剂进行神经阻滞。我笑是因为你用了“钻孔”这个词，我想向大家保证，真的不需要钻孔。整个过程只需几分钟，针头大小和新冠疫苗或流感疫苗的针头差不多。
And most people don't describe it as painful at all. They say it feels a little bit weird. And when it's over, most people just say that's it. That's all there is to it. Again, so and I think we're doing this on video, but the procedure was performed a hundred years ago by just touching next to the neck. There's a bone here at the C6 vertebrae, and then injecting along your finger, a local anesthetic. And that had been done like that for many, many years, way before the advent of ultrasound technology or fluoroscopy on thousands of people for pain conditions very successfully
大多数人并不觉得疼，只是感觉有点奇怪。结束后，大家通常会说：“这就完了？就这么简单？”再说一次，虽然我们是在录视频，但这项手术100年前就是通过触摸颈部进行的。这里有第六颈椎骨，沿着手指注射局部麻醉剂。在超声技术或透视技术出现之前，这种方法已经在成千上万的疼痛患者身上成功应用了多年，风险极低。
with very few risks. So about 12 years ago or so, a few of us, myself and my partner, Dr. Sean Mulvaney, who are the two founders here at the Stelian Institute in Annapolis, Maryland, really started adopting this and researching it in the military. And that's really where both of our roots go. Although both of us are now since retired from the U.S. Army, but we take care of trauma survivors from all backgrounds. Initially, what we ran into was primarily combat-related trauma based on the population of people we served with. But we have since learned over time that that in no way
大约12年前，我和我的合伙人Sean Mulvaney医生（我们是马里兰州安纳波利斯Stellian研究所的两位创始人）开始在军队中采用并研究这种方法。这正是我们两人的根源所在。虽然我们现在都已从美国陆军退役，但我们照顾着各种背景的创伤幸存者。起初，我们接触的主要是战斗相关的创伤，因为我们服务的群体大多是军人。但后来我们了解到，这绝不是……
is the only type of trauma background that the stellate ganglion block can be helpful for. But just to give you that again, over 10 years ago when we discovered this, there was a report, kind of a random report in the literature of someone that was shot at a close range and had severe pain from gunshot wounds to the shoulder was treated with this procedure, um, for pain, the Stella ganglion block. Um, at that time, this was a young woman, um, who had severe PTSD developed from this assault as could be imagined, but was, um, completely unable to participate in therapy because of the amount of pain or distress, psychological pain that she was having that she couldn't even go in the door to the psychotherapist. Meanwhile, she was debilitated with her trauma, her traumatic injury. After the Stahl-Ganglian block series she received, her mood changed dramatically and she became much more willing to engage in psychotherapy as her anxiety
星状神经节阻滞唯一适用的创伤类型。再举个例子，10多年前我们发现这个方法时，文献中有一份随机报告，提到一个人在近距离被枪击，因肩部枪伤导致剧烈疼痛，通过星状神经节阻滞治疗疼痛。当时，这是一位年轻女性，因这次袭击患上了严重的PTSD，但由于她承受着巨大的心理痛苦，甚至无法走进心理治疗室，完全无法参与治疗。与此同时，她被创伤性损伤折磨得虚弱不堪。在接受星状神经节阻滞系列治疗后，她的情绪发生了巨大变化，焦虑症状减轻，她变得更愿意参与心理治疗。
symptoms were dialed down so so that's really what started but but what the heck is the stellar ganglion block doing then if we're not drilling drilling holes in anything we're literally placing a numbing medicine called ropivacaine alongside a nerve in the neck but for it to make sense it has to you have to understand what the nerve is. So a lot of people who are in this area understand polyvagal theory and understand the vagus nerve, which controls the parasympathetic nervous system. And it lies also in the neck, both sides of the neck within the carotid sheath, just outside of the carotid sheath in the neck is a nerve called the cervical sympathetic chain or cervical sympathetic trunk. And this is the easiest way I'd describe it to
所以，这就是它的起源。但如果不是钻孔，星状神经节阻滞到底在做什么呢？我们实际上是在颈部神经旁放置一种叫做罗哌卡因的麻醉药。要理解这一点，必须先了解那条神经。很多关注这个领域的人都了解多迷走神经理论和迷走神经，它控制副交感神经系统。它也位于颈部，在颈动脉鞘两侧。颈动脉鞘外有一条神经，叫做颈交感神经链或颈交感神经干。这是我向患者解释时最简单的方式。
my patients or other people when I'm first describing it. So I hope this will make sense. But there are areas within the brain where the body stores threat responses. Many of your listeners know this and understand whether it's the amygdala, the prefrontal cortex, there are several connections within the brain where fear and threat centers and memories are stored. There's also several areas in the body that regulate or that feel the effects of the sympathetic nervous system. The obvious ones like the heart, the lungs, the muscles, the sweat glands, all these things are connected through a series of connections in the body, a series of connections in the brain, and all of them come together in a simple single nerve in the neck called the cervical sympathetic
希望这能讲得通。大脑中有一些区域储存着威胁反应。很多听众都知道，无论是杏仁核还是前额叶皮层，大脑中都有多个连接点储存着恐惧、威胁中心和记忆。身体中也有多个区域调节或感受交感神经系统的影响。显而易见的有心脏、肺、肌肉、汗腺，所有这些都通过一系列身体连接和大脑连接相连，它们最终汇聚在颈部的一条简单神经上，即颈交感神经干。
trunk. That's the only thing that nerve does is it carries signals in two directions, body to brain, brain to body, and that's it. And that nerve essentially can become dysfunctional in some people. And by that, I mean- Is that from an environmental thing, like a trauma happens and then that stores some information about how to communicate with the body in a way that isn't helpful? Yeah, I think so. I think it's what's interesting is what, what it takes to, to get that nerve, to stop working properly could be anything. So for some people, it's a single traumatic event that has that traumatic experience can be enough to take what's essentially a circuit, right?
那条神经唯一的功能就是双向传递信号：从身体到大脑，从大脑到身体，仅此而已。在某些人身上，这条神经会变得功能失调。我的意思是……这是环境因素导致的吗？比如发生创伤后，它储存了一些关于如何与身体沟通的信息，而这种沟通方式并无益处？是的，我想是这样。有趣的是，导致神经停止正常工作的原因可能多种多样。对某些人来说，单一的创伤事件就足以让这个回路……
Because it's going to, so we're talking brain to body, body to brain. If there is something that conditions then a fear or a threat response in the brain, it then automatically triggers the body to respond a certain way. So you can imagine then if there's some insult, I'll just say, or some experience that causes that cycle to become dysfunctional, where it's all of a sudden now feeding back on each other, you can end up with a sympathetic nervous system that's inappropriately elevated or inappropriately stimulated.
因为我们谈论的是大脑到身体、身体到大脑的循环。如果有什么东西引发了大脑中的恐惧或威胁反应，它会自动触发身体做出某种反应。所以你可以想象，如果受到某种刺激或经历导致这个循环变得功能失调，突然间它们开始相互反馈，你最终可能会得到一个过度活跃或被不当刺激的交感神经系统。
That becomes the issue that we're targeting with this particular procedure. It's the thing that. Oh think that's where the cognitive therapy breaks down is where that response that's causing panic is coming from the body and we're trying to control it totally, mind over matter, but there's a negative feedback loop where my body is agitated. So my brain is stressed. Now my brain is stressed. It's making my body more agitated and leaving the body out of it doesn't treat the trauma a lot of the time. No, I think that's the point too. And something that's probably worth noting right now is I, I never have and never do consider the stella ganglion block, some standalone therapy. And you may run across some providers that'll say,
这正是我们通过这个特定程序要解决的问题。哦，我想这就是认知疗法失效的地方，因为导致恐慌的反应来自身体，我们试图完全通过“心智控制物质”来解决，但存在一个负反馈循环：我的身体焦虑，所以大脑感到压力；现在大脑感到压力，又让身体更加焦虑。如果不处理身体，很多时候是无法治愈创伤的。是的，我认为这正是重点。现在值得注意的是，我从未也绝不会将星状神经节阻滞视为一种独立的疗法。你可能会遇到一些提供者说……
you know, I'll do this procedure and this will cure your anxiety or cure your PTSD or something like that. That's not that's not really the case. And some people might say that what I what I believe is what can happen is this dysfunctional connection between the brain and the body becomes a barrier to allowing you to just won't let you past it. And what you know, hundreds of my patients over the past 10 years have described is going to therapy and just not being able to break through. Or more importantly, I think, are the therapists I've worked with over the years who say, I just can't make the progress in therapy because the person is just, my client is just not calm enough in their body to make the
“我做这个手术就能治愈你的焦虑或PTSD。”事实并非如此。我认为，这种大脑与身体之间功能失调的连接成了一种障碍，让你无法跨越。过去10年里，我的数百名患者描述过，他们去接受心理治疗却无法取得突破。或者更重要的是，我合作过的治疗师们说，他们无法在治疗中取得进展，因为客户的身体不够平静，无法达到治疗效果。
gains that I need to do. Or what would normally take three years in therapy following the stellar ganglion block can now take, you know, three to six months or something, because we have now taken essentially these two areas of the sympathetic nervous system and uncoupled them. You can relearn how to talk. Yeah. And then, so that's an interesting point because for many people, the, the effects of the stelagandum block are immediate, meaning within minutes, just in the exam room. The way the procedure is done is in an outpatient clinic. You don't have to go to a hospital or be in a fancy surgical suite done under fluoroscopy. In fact, it's done quite safe, more safely under bedside ultrasound.
或者原本需要三年才能完成的心理治疗，在星状神经节阻滞后可能只需要三到六个月，因为我们已经将交感神经系统的这两个区域解耦了。你可以重新学习如何沟通。是的，这是一个有趣的观点。对许多人来说，星状神经节阻滞的效果是立竿见影的，几分钟内就能在检查室感受到。这个过程是在门诊进行的，不需要去医院或在昂贵的手术室进行透视。事实上，在床旁超声引导下进行非常安全。
And that's something that we do here at the Stellian Institute, you know, every day, just someone lying on the, on a patient exam table under ultrasound guidance, locating all the critical anatomy in the neck, and then really a simple ultrasound guided injection with a tiny little needle that most people feel very little at all. They say it feels a little bit weird. And then within recovery, within a few minutes in the recovery stage, people will notice things and many will actually report a physiologic release of something. And it's interesting because a lot of times it's hard to verbalize, but it's not uncommon at all for people to get quite emotional. Even people who haven't cried in many, many years may sometimes feel emotions well up or feel a release of some type of tension.
这也是我们在Stellian研究所每天都在做的事情。患者躺在检查台上，在超声引导下定位颈部的所有关键解剖结构，然后进行简单的超声引导注射，针头很小，大多数人几乎感觉不到。他们说感觉有点奇怪。在恢复阶段的几分钟内，人们会注意到一些变化，许多人会报告某种生理上的释放。有趣的是，很多时候很难用语言表达，但人们变得情绪化并不罕见。即使是多年没哭过的人，有时也会感到情绪涌动或某种紧张感的释放。
That's what I was going to ask is because we use, I'm not a practitioner of the physical therapy, but we work with ones that have an ROI sign so we can talk and they kind of feed back into each other but rolf massage or myofascial release where it's not a fun massage that's rubbing the sore place but you're kind of trying to rip the fascia and make the body unlearn how to hold an emotion those after their significant progress people just have a emotional flooding of older stuff that's not leaving brain spotting same thing i mean my experience was i've been in five different kinds of therapy, you know, they did different things, but then 30 minutes of looking at a pointer with brain spotting,
我正想问这个。虽然我不是物理治疗师，但我们与那些做罗尔夫按摩（Rolfing）或肌筋膜释放的人合作。那不是那种舒服的按摩，而是试图撕开筋膜，让身体“忘记”如何保持情绪。在取得重大进展后，人们会有旧事物的“情绪泛滥”。脑点治疗（Brainspotting）也是一样。我的经历是，我尝试过五种不同的疗法，但通过脑点治疗盯着指针看了30分钟后……
I felt this thing under my life in my body that I had been trying to turn off my whole life that I had not ever looked at that closely consciously. And then I could not turn it off. And there was two or three days of real raw emotional stuff. And then it was out, you know? so I was wondering when you hit that, does that start to what's the next couple of days look like? Does creativity come back online or is there more of an intuitive? I mean, do you notice patterns in what people report? Yeah, that's a great question. So there's two things, I guess, is we in terms of the science behind the symptoms that people have reported. These are things we've published in peer reviewedreviewed literature that can be found on the website.
我感受到了身体里一直试图压抑的东西，那是我从未如此近距离审视过的。然后我就无法再压抑它了。经历了二到三天的真实、原始的情绪波动，然后它就释放了。所以我很好奇，当你达到那个点时，接下来的几天会是什么样子？创造力会恢复吗？还是会有更多的直觉？你是否注意到人们报告的模式？是的，这是一个很好的问题。关于人们报告的症状背后的科学，我们已经在同行评审的文献中发表过，可以在网站上找到。
The actual symptoms, you know, using DSM-5 criteria for things, those things are on there. The thing that's not, I think, is when you sit in the room with somebody after the procedure, and we just have some quiet music playing, and I sit in there, and I just allow people to relax, and I tell, you know, sometimes I'm not a therapist, so I don't, I don't pretend to be a therapist, but I'll just encourage people to let their, their brains go. If they've been trained in relaxation techniques, I help, you know, reinforce that that's a good time to do that, whether it's belly breathing or other things. And then the themes that people will, will report are actually quite interesting just that day. And the words that people will use to describe the feeling after a stellaganglion block are things like light or calm or more clear.
实际的症状，比如使用DSM-5标准，都在上面。我认为没有被记录的是，当你在手术后和某人坐在房间里，放着安静的音乐，我坐在那里，让人们放松。我不是治疗师，所以我不会假装是，但我会鼓励人们让大脑放松。如果他们受过放松技巧训练，我会强化那是练习的好时机，无论是腹式呼吸还是其他。人们报告的主题在那一天其实非常有趣。人们用来描述星状神经节阻滞后感觉的词汇是“轻盈”、“平静”或“清晰”。
Many people describe they feel instant and immediate calm and their muscles relax and some type of a calm come over their entire body. So a physiologic thing as well as that mental thing. People also know a clarity of thinking. That one is still intrigues me, but people will use the different words to describe it as if the swirling thoughts in their heads have now calmed down, right? They can now just concentrate and think on one topic without balls bouncing around inside their head. And these are kind of the immediate, immediate things that people describe. What I think over the course of the next few days that many, many have reported back to me is the things that would normally upset you might still be there. And I think this is important
许多人描述他们感到瞬间的平静，肌肉放松，某种平静感笼罩全身。这既是生理上的，也是心理上的。人们还感到思维清晰。这一点仍然让我着迷，但人们会用不同的词来描述它，仿佛脑海中盘旋的思绪现在平静下来了。他们现在可以专注于一个话题，而不会有杂念在脑子里乱撞。这些是人们描述的即时感受。我认为在接下来的几天里，许多人反馈说，那些通常会让你心烦的事情可能依然存在。我认为这一点很重要……
because it reinforces the point that this procedure is not a magic wand and it could be anything right it could be the slow driver in the left lane it could be you know your kid dropping a plate and a loud noise or something those things will probably still bother you but what the block may do is uncouple that immediate and autonomic or automatic response that you couldn't control before so that you would always just go zero to 60 if something happened and you had no control over that it was completely um reflexive for you what most people response is happening before thought even it's happening before conscious language-based prefrontal cortex thought so it's not something that you could sit and have insight
因为它强化了一个观点：这个程序不是魔杖。可能是任何事情，比如左车道上的慢车，或者孩子摔碎盘子发出的巨响。这些事情可能仍然会困扰你，但阻滞的作用可能是解耦了那种你以前无法控制的即时、自主或自动的反应。以前你遇到事情总是会瞬间“从0加速到60”，你对此毫无控制力，完全是反射性的。大多数人的反应发生在思考之前，甚至发生在基于语言的前额叶皮层意识思考之前。所以这不是你能通过内省就能消除的。
into to make it go away no and i think that think that's, you know, to your question, I think that's the thing that's interesting is people will then feel harmed and able to actually deflect that, which is interesting. And that people use different words to describe that. Like, I got a little bit of headspace. I got a little bit of leg room back. I got just enough time where I don't have to fly off the handle. And I realize this is something that would really upset me previously,
不，我认为这就是有趣的地方。人们会感到能够抵御那种反应，这很有趣。人们用不同的词来描述它，比如“我获得了一点心理空间”、“我找回了一点余地”。我有足够的时间不至于立刻发火。我意识到这在以前确实会让我非常心烦……
but I seem to be fine right now. And those could be other things like just being in a public place or, you know, the example comes up all the time of, you know, going to a restaurant and maybe not having to have your back to the wall now, or a loud noise, you may maybe don't respond the same way. So it's, i look at it as something that allows the um the automatic uncoupling of the body and the brain through the sympathetic nervous system i do think the people that have had deep-seated issues for long periods of time there's also an unlearning effect that happens and i think you said something earlier that made me made me think of that um some people do very very well automatically feeling much better
但我现在似乎没事了。这可能包括在公共场所，或者像大家常说的去餐馆吃饭时不再需要背靠墙坐，或者遇到巨响时反应不再那么强烈。所以我认为它是一种通过交感神经系统实现身体与大脑自动解耦的方法。对于那些长期有深层问题的人，我认为也存在一种“去学习”的效果。你之前说的话让我想到了这一点。有些人自动感觉好多了……
and to give that a number what we typically see is a 50% decrease in symptoms using whether it's a gad 7 or PCL 5 type score 50% drop in symptoms some people feel so good that they feel uncomfortable and I think that that's worth noting there some people oh my god I'm felt this good and so long it feels weird and then that that's worth noting there. Some people are just, Oh my God, I haven't felt this good in so long. It feels weird. And then that's where they work with their therapist to kind of get, get used to this new period or new phase of kind of unlearning some of the
为了量化这一点，我们通常看到症状减少了50%，无论是使用GAD-7还是PCL-5评分。有些人感觉太好了，以至于感到不舒服，我认为这一点值得注意。有些人会说：“天哪，我太久没感觉这么好了，这感觉很奇怪。”然后他们会与治疗师合作，去适应这个新的阶段，去“去学习”那些安全反应，比如“如果我感觉良好，那是不好的，因为这会被夺走。一旦我感觉良好，我就会受到惩罚。”你知道，在某些创伤中，当身体症状平静下来时，可能会产生一种更清醒的恐慌反应：“哦不，这很糟糕，我不被允许有这种感觉。”
safety response of if I'm feeling good, then that's bad because it's going to be taken away. As soon as I'm feeling good, I'm going to be punished. You know, that you get in some trauma when the body symptoms calm down, there's probably a more conscious panic response of, oh no, this is bad. I'm not allowed to feel like that. Yeah. There's, and I think that's a good point. And I think that's really one of the key things is for me, not a therapist who does the procedure. It's always
是的，这是一个很好的观点。对我这个做手术的非治疗师来说，这非常重要……
important to me that I, that I reinforce, Hey, we, we should try to tee this up so that you have an appointment with your therapist within the week or so afterwards. And I think that's critical. It allows people to just, you know, do this as a, as a team, not just, you know, some doctors somewhere off in Maryland is doing his own thing. So, uh, I really welcome that. And I find, um, that a critical component is if I'm working with new therapists that are not familiar with the block, I'm happy to take a phone call or an email or something just to work through like, okay, what's a good way to do this as a team? Yeah, the integrative approach is so important. I mean, that's one of the things that we work with. I mean, 90% of the calls that we get, we're never going to see those people's
我总是强调，我们应该安排好时间，让你在手术后一周左右与治疗师预约。我认为这至关重要。它让人们能够作为一个团队来完成这件事，而不是某个在马里兰州的医生在自顾自地做。所以我非常欢迎这种方式。我发现，如果我与不熟悉阻滞疗法的治疗师合作，我很乐意通过电话或邮件沟通，共同探讨如何以团队形式进行。是的，整合方法非常重要。我们处理的90%的咨询，我们可能永远见不到那些患者，但我们确保他们能得到所需的东西。我们不提供氯胺酮，不提供药物，不提供神经刺激……
patients, but we make sure that they're going to get what they need. We don't provide ketamine, we don't provide medication, we don't provide neur they need. We don't provide ketamine. We don't provide medication. We don't provide neurostim. We don't provide stellate ganglion blocking. We don't provide different kinds of massage. And one day maybe I'd like to, but, you know, with the massage and some other things, but we're able to figure out what you need.
我们不提供星状神经节阻滞，不提供各种按摩。也许有一天我想提供，但目前我们能帮你找出你需要什么。
Do you need one or two? You know, if you're going to do brain spotting, let's get you with a Rolf massage person. If ketamine or neurostim or stellate ganglion is better. I mean, one, the podcast is helpful because we can just send the interview with the provider to the person and they're hearing it i'm not just giving my impression badly of what i remember um but uh the issue we've run in with stelagangolin is just that their people do it here but they won't do it for trauma they want to do it for fibromyalgia and pain phantom pain
你需要一两次吗？如果你要做脑点治疗，我们会帮你联系罗尔夫按摩师。如果氯胺酮、神经刺激或星状神经节阻滞更好。播客很有帮助，因为我们可以直接把采访发给对方，他们听的是专业人士的讲解，而不是我凭记忆转述的错误印象。但我们遇到的问题是，有些人虽然做星状神经节阻滞，但他们不针对创伤做，他们只想做纤维肌痛、疼痛或幻痛……
disorders but they won't screen the patient and see them for trauma they don't have a protocol for that or use it yeah yeah it's too bad it's so that's probably one of the most important things to say about the whole um the whole topic for anyone who's listening to this is saying hey this sounds like a pretty good deal why haven't't I heard of this before? There's a complicated answer to that question. But certainly one of the barriers is the fact that insurance does not pay for this procedure for behavioral health issues. And that's a significant barrier. Depending on where you look around the country, a lot of people charge somewhere around $3,000 for the procedure. At our clinic here in Annapolis, Maryland, which is right outside Baltimore and DC, we charge $1,200. And both myself and my partner,
他们不会筛选患者，也不会针对创伤进行诊疗，他们没有相应的方案。是的，太可惜了。对于任何听到这里的人来说，这可能是最重要的一点：“听起来是个好办法，为什么我以前没听说过？”这个问题答案很复杂。但障碍之一肯定是保险不支付这种行为健康问题的费用。这是一个重大障碍。在全国范围内，很多人收费在3000美元左右。在我们位于马里兰州安纳波利斯的诊所（就在巴尔的摩和华盛顿特区外），我们收费1200美元。我和我的合伙人……
Dr. Mulvaney, were the, probably fair to say the, if not the two most experienced, two of the most experienced in the procedure in the world, were the ones that have written published most of the original research on this over the past 10 years and when i retired from the army i came here specifically to join up with him so that we could form a center of excellence um having said all that you know we we try to make the procedure within reach and i i think a 1200 procedure is not within reach of many many people it isn't that's fair. That's a better price than we've seen anywhere, though. I mean, I was seeing $3,000 and $4,000 when I was looking at different places. Yeah, you'll see that amount of money. And I think other providers will do it under fluoroscopy in an OR suite. Some will use sedation, which we
Mulvaney医生，可以说是世界上最有经验的两位医生。过去10年里，大部分关于此的研究都是我们撰写和发表的。我从军队退役后，专门来到这里与他汇合，组建了一个卓越中心。话虽如此，我们尽量让这个程序触手可及，但我认为1200美元对很多人来说仍然难以负担。确实如此。不过这比我见过的任何地方的价格都要好。我看到过3000到4000美元的价格。是的，你会看到那个价位。我认为其他提供者会在手术室进行透视引导，有些人会使用镇静剂，我们这里不使用，也不认为有必要。事实上，我们认为那是有害的。所以我们不用。而且如我所说，我们做的比任何人都多。我们花很多时间在患者身上，这是另一回事。我认为大多数地方你去做手术，医生只跟你聊几分钟。我喜欢在患者来时花近一个小时。因为如果你要找医生做这种手术，你想要获得他们的经验，想听听他们的建议，想有机会提问。至少我是这么认为的。
do not do here, nor do we believe that that's necessary. In fact, believe that that has harm associated with it. So, so we don't. And like I said, we've done more than anybody else. And we, we spend a lot of time with our patients is the other thing. I think most places you go and you get a procedure, doc talks to you for a couple of minutes. And I like to spend, you know, close to an hour with my, my patients when they come. because I think if you're going to come and have some provider do a procedure like this, you want to get their experience. You want to hear from them. You want an opportunity to ask questions. You want to, you know, I don't think, at least that's what I think.
（注：原文此处重复，已合并）
Spending an hour with a doctor is not common. I mean, your psychiatrist sees you for three minutes and writes a script when they hear anxiety three times. Yeah. So it's not their fault all the time. I mean, the industry realities in the industry that are not good forced changes and doctors and providers that weren't. It's not always their fault. Yeah. No, I think you're right, Joel.
花一个小时和医生交流并不常见。你的精神科医生通常只看你三分钟，听到三次“焦虑”就给你开药。是的，这并不总是他们的错。行业现实导致了不好的变化，医生和提供者被迫改变。这并不总是他们的错。是的，你说得对，Joel。
And when you're limited to insurance and all the wickets that happen happen like that you're kind of shoved into a hole so in until insurance covers this um we'll continue to do what we're doing and then i guess the silver lining of that is we can take as much time as we'd like and provide the type of personalized care as we can without someone you know whipping us like like the rest of the medical community for right now. So I guess that's the good. Can people push the AMA and the APA to try and force insurance providers to cover it? To say that this is what's needed? I mean, there's this view that you have cognitive therapy and CBT just take over in the 80s and the 90s.
当你受限于保险和各种条条框框时，你就像被塞进了一个洞里。所以在保险覆盖之前，我们会继续做我们正在做的事。一线希望是，我们可以花尽可能多的时间，提供个性化的护理，而不必像医疗界的其他人那样被鞭策。所以我想这就是好处。人们能推动美国医学会（AMA）和美国心理学会（APA）去强制保险公司覆盖它吗？去说这是必要的？人们有一种观点，认为认知疗法和CBT在80和90年代占据了主导地位。
And a lot of it's reaction to psychoanalysis takes 20 years. We don't want to pay for that. want something faster but I mean you do have this attitude that will the body's a go-kart that carries the brain around if your body's sick go to the doctor if your brain is sick go to the therapist or the psychiatrist and that just isn't how it works I mean the neuroscience we have now is like it's in the interplay between those things and the emotional and the cognitive so I mean how fast do you see that changing? And what's the best way to kind of lobby the this unhealthy system to be
很多是对精神分析需要20年治疗的一种反弹。我们不想付那么多钱，想要更快的东西。但你确实有一种态度，认为身体是一辆载着大脑的卡丁车，身体病了去看医生，大脑病了去看治疗师或精神科医生，但这根本不是运作方式。我们现在拥有的神经科学表明，它是两者之间以及情感与认知之间的相互作用。那么你认为这种改变有多快？推动这个不健康的系统做出改变的最佳方式是什么？
different? Yeah, I love I love it. I spent so in the in the 10 years or so that I've been doing the procedure, so I'm a full time clinician, you know, I'm seeing patients all day every day. We are still conducting research because we believe Dr. Mulvaney and I both believe that you're going to be relevant, you got got to keep studying what you're doing, keep making it better. So we're currently doing a randomized control trial with Ohio State University right now that we're paired with for a study that we're currently doing. We've got more in the chute.
是的，我喜欢这个问题。在我做这个手术的10年里，我是一名全职临床医生，每天都在看病人。我们仍在进行研究，因为Mulvaney医生和我坚信，要保持相关性，就必须不断研究你所做的事情，不断改进。我们目前正在与俄亥俄州立大学进行一项随机对照试验。我们还有更多研究正在筹备中。
And then really the advocacy piece has been a major piece for me. What earlier on when I was in the military, the advocacy was was designed for military active duty military and the veteran population. And it's been, you know, pushing a rock uphill for 10 years, frankly, it's just trying to change large organizations, what's available, what's covered. But I think we made some gains within that community. So there are VA hospitals who will offer the Stella Ganglion Block at no cost to veterans. There's just not that many of them. They're kind of sprinkled around the country. They have kind of mixed experience levels, and it comes up a lot. So we do take care of veterans and military who who don't have access to those um will come to see us as well but but to me the the now that i've been you know um focused a lot on on the
倡导工作对我来说也是重要的一部分。早些时候在军队里，倡导工作是针对现役军人和退伍军人群体的。坦白说，过去10年就像推石头上山，试图改变大型组织、可用资源和覆盖范围。但我认为我们在那个群体中取得了一些进展。现在有一些退伍军人医院免费为退伍军人提供星状神经节阻滞。只是数量不多，散布在全国各地，经验水平参差不齐。我们确实照顾那些无法获得这些资源的退伍军人和军人，他们也会来找我们。但对我来说，现在我……
other eight million trauma survivors in the us is how do we how do we get that offered um you know across the board and i just think to answer your question how do do we best do it? I think what you're doing right now, you know, spreading the word, raising awareness with a, you know, a podcast is helpful. I think that patients that are, that may have influence, talking to the right people might help. I just am a little jaded at this point that it's just a glacial process. And although it doesn't make any sense to me that a, that a procedure that's been safely performed for 100 years that costs very little money and is very safe when performed by the right people and has an immediate impact, why that wouldn't be covered compared to all the other things that insurance pays for that doesn't make any sense.
关注美国另外800万创伤幸存者，如何让它全面普及？回答你的问题，我们如何最好地做到这一点？我认为你现在所做的，通过播客传播信息、提高意识很有帮助。我认为有影响力的患者去和关键人物沟通可能会有帮助。但我现在有点厌倦了，因为这是一个极其缓慢的过程。虽然我无法理解，为什么一个已经安全执行了100年、成本很低、由专业人员操作非常安全且有立竿见影效果的程序，在保险覆盖方面却不如其他那些毫无意义的项目。
It's just I'll just keep pushing the advocacy and awareness piece and hopefully the right people will catch attention to get the reimbursement piece caught up to us. I think it is more of a philosophical fear maybe than even a practical one that there's these, that if you start to rethink about medicine in this way, that the environment is a bigger variable, then how does one, how do you research it? Because there's too many variables and it's too big
我只会继续推动倡导和意识工作，希望合适的人能注意到，让报销政策跟上我们的步伐。我认为这可能更多是一种哲学上的恐惧，而不仅仅是实际上的。如果你开始以这种方式重新思考医学，认为环境是一个更大的变量，那么该如何研究它呢？因为变量太多，规模太大……
and we want something where we can get it small and research it easy. But then also you're you're saying that medicine needs to be more integrative than it is and that i think that's a threat to a lot of um different parts of the current system yeah it is it's also just not what people are accustomed to on learning in my practice in north carolina i had, I had an office, I had right outside my office, two psychologists and a social worker. And we talked regularly. And, and that's not the case of where I am now in Maryland. So I've made efforts to try to
我们想要那种可以缩小范围、容易研究的东西。但你同时也说医学需要比现在更具整合性，我认为这对当前系统的许多部分构成了威胁。是的，这确实不是人们习惯的学习方式。在北卡罗来纳州执业时，我的办公室外就有两位心理学家和一位社会工作者。我们经常交流。但在马里兰州的现在情况并非如此。所以我努力尝试……
build those types of relationships and bridges with community providers around the state. But it's definitely not what people are accustomed to or what we're used to doing. So, but I don't care. We'll keep trying to do that. And I think people like it. I think that clinicians who want to take care of people, I think more and more are starting to see that, hey, this is okay. Teamwork's okay. I don't have to have all the answers myself. It's okay to reach across the aisle and ask someone from a different discipline to weigh in on stuff and and that's my hope at least is that that will um hit a tipping
建立与州内社区提供者之间的关系和桥梁。但这绝对不是人们习惯的或我们习惯做的事情。但我不在乎，我们会继续尝试。我认为人们喜欢这样。我认为那些想要照顾好人的临床医生，越来越多地开始看到：团队合作是可以的。我不必自己拥有所有答案。跨越学科去询问不同领域的人的意见是可以的。至少这是我的希望，它会在某个时刻达到临界点……
point at some point and and people will become much more comfortable with reaching outside their discipline to do something that maybe they weren't trained of in their in their training but it's the kind of thing that they realize now there's plenty of evidence to support. Well, I want to be respectful of your time. I know you need to hop off. I just, I mean, I guess to close, we'll link to the website and everything so people can find you and your research. But I mean, if somebody is sitting there with trauma and they're trying to decide between ketamine, which is IV ketamine is expensive and not covered by insurance, Stelaganglion,
人们会变得更加习惯于跨学科寻求帮助，去做一些他们受训时没学过，但现在意识到有充分证据支持的事情。好吧，我想尊重你的时间。我知道你需要离开了。最后，我们会链接到网站和所有内容，以便人们找到你和你的研究。如果有人正带着创伤，试图在氯胺酮（静脉注射很贵且保险不覆盖）、星状神经节阻滞……
you know, NeuroStim is expensive and not covered by insurance. Brain spotting, if the provider knows a lot and has a bunch of the somatic training, then they're probably expensive. Maybe, I mean, that's the cheapest option, but it's still an investment. I mean, where do I start? What do I do if I'm looking
神经刺激（很贵且保险不覆盖）、脑点治疗（如果提供者经验丰富且有大量躯体训练，通常也很贵）之间做选择。也许脑点治疗是最便宜的选择，但仍然是一项投资。我该从哪里开始？如果我正在寻找这些令人兴奋的新事物，我该怎么办？
at these new exciting things? That's a good question. I think to answer this part, if you're interested in Stella Ganglion Block and you just have a lot more questions, for sure, look at our website, which I think you'll probably post up on a graphic, I guess. But it's thestellainstitute.com, all one word, dot com. On it, there's a whole slew of testimonials that I think are helpful for the personal story. But there's also full text journal articles of all the research that we publish on the evidence tab.
这是一个好问题。如果你对星状神经节阻滞感兴趣，还有更多疑问，请务必查看我们的网站，我想你会把它贴在图表上。网址是thestellainstitute.com，全部连在一起。上面有大量的感言，我认为对了解个人故事很有帮助。在“证据”标签页下，还有我们发表的所有研究的全文期刊文章。
And then on the FAQ page, we try to answer literally all the frequently asked questions we get. And then there's videos in there, too. And they're all on YouTube as well. But the videos are to answer questions that are a little bit more, you know, sophisticated that you can't answer in a little three line sentence. So I would encourage people to do their homework because I think it matters. And I think if it's the right, it sounds like the right thing for you. If you're a therapist looking at your client saying, Hey, I think this person could really benefit from this, and then coming back to see me in therapy. Hopefully, a
在常见问题解答页面，我们尝试回答了所有收到的常见问题。里面也有视频，YouTube上也有。视频是为了回答一些更复杂、无法用三行字解释的问题。所以我鼓励大家做功课，因为这很重要。如果这对你来说是正确的选择，如果你是一位治疗师，看着你的客户说：“我认为这个人真的能从中受益，然后再回来找我进行心理治疗。”希望……
lot of the answers to your questions are on that website. As far as how to get scheduled. At our place, we take either two things, some people will refer scheduled, at our place, we take either two things. Some people will refer themselves, which is fine in terms of access, preferably if there's a therapist who has a client to refer. I would love to do that, receive that from you. And we have a simple referral form that's on our website as well. If you scroll through the instructions, there's a hyperlink to a simple form. When in doubt, old school is fine with me, and I'm happy to take an email or a phone call with, hey, how do I make this work? But to try
您问题的许多答案都在那个网站上。关于如何预约，在我们这里，我们接受两种方式，有些人会选择自行预约，这在获取服务方面是可以的，但如果有一位治疗师能转介客户，那是最好的。我很乐意收到您的转介。我们的网站上也有一个简单的转介表格。如果您浏览说明，会有一个指向简单表格的超链接。如果有疑问，用老派的方式也可以，我很乐意通过电子邮件或电话沟通，询问如何操作。但为了尝试
to answer all those questions, we loaded it all up in kind of a contact us piece on our website to answer those things. As far as trying to decide which other modality to do, that's the million- dollar question. I have people come that have tried everything or they're in the process of trying everything. The only advice I'd have is if you're methodical about that, what can I try now to see if it makes a difference and then give it a little bit of time so you're not stacking things up together. And I have some people that will come and they say, well, I'm in the middle of a ketamine treatment. I'm doing this, I'm adding this. And I think that's okay. Like I'm happy to help you. But I think when it's,
回答所有这些问题，我们将所有内容都放在了网站的“联系我们”板块中。至于如何决定尝试哪种其他疗法，这是一个价值百万美元的问题。我遇到过尝试过所有方法或者正在尝试所有方法的人。我唯一的建议是，如果您对此有条理，可以尝试现在做些什么来看看是否有改变，然后给它一点时间，这样您就不会把所有事情堆在一起。有些人来的时候会说，我正在进行氯胺酮治疗，我正在做这个，我正在增加那个。我觉得这没问题，我很乐意为您提供帮助。但我认为当它是，
when you get better, you're going to want to know which one it was that really helped. Although having said that, sometimes it just turns out to be a whole slew of things or a combination of things. So I wish i could give a better answer to that because i think that's the question and part of the the um the research that we're doing right now is to try to answer that question which is we feel fairly comfortable still getting any black works okay got it now what does it work best with how do we combine it with certain things so i think that's the next phase of what we're doing in research wise. Well, it was fascinating and I don't want to make you run late, but I really appreciate your time and hopefully and maybe if there's questions
当您好转时，您会想知道到底是哪一种方法真正起到了作用。尽管如此，有时结果往往是一系列事情或多种事物的组合。所以我希望我能给出更好的答案，因为我认为这就是问题所在，我们目前正在进行的部分研究就是为了尝试回答这个问题，即我们仍然对氯胺酮有效感到相当满意，明白了，那么它与什么配合效果最好？我们如何将其与某些事物结合？所以我认为这是我们研究方面的下一个阶段。嗯，这非常引人入胜，我不想让您迟到，但我真的很感谢您的时间，希望也许如果有问题
or something we can do a part two, I don't know how much we'll, we'll see where it goes, but I really appreciate it. Thank you so much. Joel, appreciate your interest and thanks for what you do. Yeah. Thank you. All right. So that was our interview with Dr. James Lynch. If you want to check out more information on him, you can go to his website, which is drjameslynch.com. Again, that's drjameslynch.com, and thank you for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者我们可以做第二部分，我不知道我们会做多少，我们会看看进展如何，但我真的很感激。非常感谢。Joel，感谢您的关注，也感谢您所做的工作。是的，谢谢。好的，以上就是我们对James Lynch医生的采访。如果您想查看关于他的更多信息，可以访问他的网站drjameslynch.com。再说一遍，是drjameslynch.com，感谢您的收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。